hola y seguimos aquí con esta
oportunidad de entrevistar a dos mujeres
extraordinarias dos venezolanas que han
decidido hacer algo para cambiar ellas
son
deborah reuters y vanessa más y mil y
las dos son comunicadores sociales y
escribieron un libro del año pasado que
se llama venezolana que soñaron en con
cambiar el mundo y lo lograron hoy vamos
a hablar un poco de eso y bueno con esa
de ahora bienvenidas a esto que será una
de ellas con perspectiva mente en los 3
muchas gracias les besa muchísimas
gracias yo lo que quisiera preguntarles
a ustedes es este que la llevó a
escribir un libro
mira desde que tenemos recuerdo los
libros han sido parte de nuestro día a
día de gente o tigrito conejo la pulga y
el piojo el barco de camila pasando
después por el mundo fantástico de harry
potter y llegamos hasta clásicos de la
literatura como casa muerta hace años
esto le da doña bárbara
desde pequeños nuestros padres se
sentaban con nosotros a contar unos
cuentos sobre mundos fantásticos y
personajes maravillosos en los que por
supuesto después de leer seguíamos con
miles de preguntas que podrían durar
para siempre si nos permitía en los
viajes de más nos faltaba un libro en la
maleta de mano y ganas de compartir cada
capítulo leido entonces nosotros
crecimos con libros como parte de
nuestras vidas y ahora somos nosotros
las que nos sentamos con nuestros hijos
a conocer personajes curiosos e
interesantes que nos enseñan sobre
emociones sobre universos sobre
amistades que nos ilustran experiencia
del día a día y de alguna manera nos
muestran que todo es posible
ahora verdad somos nosotras las que
damos un beso buenas noches que los
invitamos a recorrer viajes únicos a
conocer monstruos de colores a
redescubrir historias que una vez para
nosotras eran conocidas somos nosotras
verdades que aprovechamos estos cuentos
para explicar las cosas que muchas veces
ellos no entienden sobre el mundo que
nos rodea y mostrarles como las cosas
cotidianas pueden ser realmente
fascinantes entonces los libros fueron
son y seguirán siendo una constante y un
elemento clave en nuestra vida
como dice de bueno los libros siempre
han sido una parte fundamental de
nuestra vida y en nuestra educación y
peros entendíamos que así queríamos
enseñar e inspirar la mejor manera de
hacerlo era a través de un libro los
libros son como máquinas del tiempo que
disfrutamos en presente pero que nos
traen del pasado parte de nuestra
memoria colectiva de nuestra herencia
cultural y que además nos llevan al
futuro porque son un motor para soñar
para inspirarnos y para crear cosas
nuevas
hubo una niña llamada ana teresa de la
parra que se enamoró de la literatura
con autores como inclán santa teresa de
la cruz y ellos fueron los que la
motivaron a escribir toda esa sabiduría
contenida en las páginas de un libro
cambió el rumbo de la vida de teresa y
la llevó a escribir memorias de mamá
blanca ifigenia que a su vez nos
inspiraron a nosotras a incluir a teresa
en este libro y lo hicimos esperando
continuar también esa cadena de
inspiración
quisimos incentivar a otra generación a
que continuara leyendo y que quizás
algún en algún momento escriban también
sus propias páginas
y esto es precisamente la magia de la
palabra escrita que permanece que no es
que forma parte de un libro forma parte
de nuestra historia como país en nuestra
historia como el mundo como humanidad y
se quede allí para siempre porque se
queda esperando volver a la vida ante
los ojos del lector y formar parte de
una nueva narrativa y una nueva idea que
continúe enseñando a través del tiempo
porque las ideas son como como la
energía que no se no se crea ni se
destruye se transforma pero para que se
transformen es necesario que se mueva
que se alimenten de otras ideas que se
enfrenten a ideas más grandes que viajen
que vivan y definitivamente el mejor
hábito para las ideas son los libros
fíjense qué maravilloso enfoque que nos
cuentan y que las motivó ustedes a
escribir un libro sobre mujeres
bueno nosotros somos parte de una
generación de niñas que creció leyendo
cuentos de princesas la cenicienta la
sirenita blancanieves y si nos ponemos a
pensar en los mensajes detrás de estos
cuentos nos damos cuenta que crecimos
con ideas como que lo mejor que nos
puede pasar en la vida es enamorar un
príncipe en una fiesta y sin cambiar más
de dos palabras o que nuestro destino es
quedarnos durmiendo esperando que venga
un príncipe azul a rescatarnos y esto
que puede parecer una exageración para
algunos son ideas que poco a poco se
fueron quedando en el subconsciente de
esta generación de niñas que tuvo muy
pocos modelos de mujeres de éxito que
admirar por suerte muchos tuvimos en
nuestra casa también ejemplos de súper
mujeres papas feministas que nos
enseñaron que nuestros sueños no tenían
límites
y esto nos ayudó pero siempre el
estereotipo estuvo allí y continuo allí
por eso cuando nos convertimos nosotras
en madres decidimos que queríamos hacer
las cosas diferentes y que queríamos
darles otros ejemplos y otras heroínas
dicen que somos un promedio de las
personas que conocemos del arte que
consumimos de las películas que vemos y
de los libros que leemos por supuesto
pero especialmente durante la infancia
porque estas ideas que aprendemos en los
primeros años de nuestras vidas son las
que van a determinar la manera en la que
pensábamos y la que sentimos el mundo
entonces los libros las películas los
mails los medios de comunicación en
general son los que escriben la realidad
porque lo que no está allí no existe
entonces si tenemos un mundo del cine y
un mundo editorial y un mundo digital
dominado por hombres lo que pasa muchas
veces es que las mujeres quedan
relegadas a un segundo plano son
personajes secundarios se ven desde la
superficie realmente si queremos un
mundo más igual necesitamos amplificar
las voces de nuestras mujeres que se lea
y se estudie sobre ellas que se hable
sobre ellas y sobre todo que se muestre
el mundo desde
perspectiva femenina por eso fue que
nosotras quisimos que las protagonistas
de nuestro libro fueron mujeres
si tal como dijo vanessa con este libro
lo que queremos mostrar la historia de
mujeres venezolanas que se atrevieron a
soñar en grande mujeres determinadas
creativas perseverantes que han cambiado
el mundo cada una a su manera cada uno
dentro de su ramo pero que no
necesariamente están en libros de
historia o están en redes sociales
nuestra idea de decirle a las niñas que
nos dejen que están capaz de resaltar en
cualquier área que éste proponga que
pueden salir del molde y la mejor manera
de hacerlo es mostrándoles referentes
que admirar referente con los que se
identifican entonces escogimos mujeres
venezolanas que si bien son talentosas y
disciplinadas no son perfectas pero
estos son reales
mujeres que muchas veces se conocen de
nombre pero que sus obstáculos los
sacrificios sus recorridos son conocidos
por pocos y para hacer una historia
amigo cada vez quedando más en el olvido
entonces con el libro de alguna manera
queremos rescatar estas historias
rescatar lo que nuestra herencia como
sociedad pero también invitar a las
niñas a soñar entendiendo que estos
sueños pueden hacerse realidad con
trabajo y esfuerzo que no hay meta que
no pueden lograr y por otro lado
queremos convertir a los varones en una
fuente de apoyo en un aliado que admiran
a las mujeres queremos mostrarles que
las niñas son capaces de todo queremos
normalizar la idea de que si las niñas
pueden ser magníficas bailarinas pues
las venezolanas puede ganar certámenes
de belleza pero también pueden ser
excelentes deportistas científicas
asombrosas destacar en área tecnología o
incluso trabajar en la nasa
fíjense que este es que interesante dos
comunicadoras que se ponen de acuerdo
quieren llevar un libro son mujeres
sobre las mujeres que han logrado cosas
maravillosas es un proceso de
aprendizaje me imagino yo que
aprendieron ustedes que nos pueden decir
de este proceso que ustedes misma
tuvieron mira lo primero que queremos
destacar es que desde que empezamos este
proceso nos permitió redescubrir el
feminismo nos dimos cuenta que el
feminismo se ha convertido en un término
muy incómodo dentro de ciertos grupos
tanto de hombres como de mujeres muchas
mujeres pero asocian con actitudes
extremas hasta violenta a muchos hombres
los rechazan sin ni siquiera entender lo
que realmente implica entonces antes de
seguir es importante decir que para
nosotras feminismo igualdad de
oportunidades que tanto los hombres como
las mujeres tengan una voz que sea
escuchada y aceptada tal como lo dice
malayos offside feminismo es otra manera
de decir igualdad una persona feminista
es aquella persona que cree en el poder
y la capacidad de un hombre así como
entienden en el poder y la capacidad de
una mujer el feminismo no busca ser una
mujer fuerte busca empoderar la para
que ella entienda lo fuerte y capaz que
ya es entonces éste un libro feminista
entre otras cosas sí pero es solo para
niñas claro que no como hemos dicho ya
antes lo que queremos es que los hombres
y las mujeres sepan que todos merecemos
igualdad oportunidades que todos
merecemos ser escuchados y como madres
creemos que la mejor manera de combatir
ciertos estereotipos que están muy
pegados a nuestra cultura es mostrarles
de temprano estos referentes digna
admirada estos referentes que son una
señal de superación porque creemos que
la educación es el remedio para la
ignorancia y para poder avanzar como
sociedad y parte de ese redescubrimiento
a lo que he feminismo fue también
entender lo necesario que es hablar del
legado de estas venezolanos lo
importante que es recordar que las
libertades de las que gozamos hoy las
mujeres las tenemos gracias al trabajo y
a la perseverancia de otras muchas
mujeres que poco a poco fueron pasando
el camino entonces no nos podemos
olvidar
bueno que si la labor de mercedes pulido
de briseñas por ejemplo el amor es no
tendríamos hoy los derechos que tenemos
sobre los hijos o kelly emberg no
solamente fue la primera mujer en
graduarse de médico en venezuela sino
que su impecable trayectoria fue
testimonio de lo que las mujeres somos
capaces de hacer y otra de las cosas que
descubrimos fue que si hay una
generación de nuevas madres en la que
nos incluimos nosotras también que está
enseñando está criando a sus hijas cada
vez es una perspectiva más feminista y
les decimos que pueden ser lo que ellas
quieran que son capaces que son fuertes
que no hay una manera correcta o
incorrecta de ser niñas pero ahora
tenemos que incluir también en esa
narrativa a los varones y no sólo
enseñándoles que tienen que respetar a
la niña a las niñas que por supuesto sus
partes pero también terminando con esas
ideas preconcebidas de lo que significa
ser hombre porque muchas veces
escuchamos que bueno que los niños no
lloran que los niños no juegan con
muñecas y estas creencias los terminan
limitando no les permiten ser personas
más sensibles más empáticas no les
permiten comunicarse abierta
entonces el feminismo busca liberar de
estereotipos a las mujeres pero también
a los hombres si queremos expandir los
papeles de la mujer en la sociedad
tenemos que expandir también los de los
hombres si queremos más mujeres ocupando
cargos que tradicionalmente hemos
ocupado a los hombres entonces
necesitábamos llevar a los hombres
también a esos terrenos donde
tradicionalmente encontramos a las
mujeres y que se involucre en con las
responsabilidades el hogar con las
crianzas de los hijos y por eso que para
nosotros es tan importante que este
mensaje llegue tanto a niñas como a
niños y otra de las cosas que
descubrimos en este proceso otro de los
aprendizajes ha sido la importancia de
mantener vivos los libros vivimos en un
mundo del best y meros a todos los días
nos llegan mareas de contenido en la que
nos perdemos y en la que también se
pierde lo importante porque al final
entre tanto ruido se confunde la
información y nos terminamos quedando en
la superficie no con lo pasajero
y por eso es que de alguna manera
necesitamos menos pantallas y más libros
uno de los grandes retos que tuvimos
nosotros en este proceso de
investigación para encontrar fuentes
fiables porque en general se ha escrito
tampoco sobre estas mujeres que
esperamos que estos pequeños historias
que nosotras escribimos lleven siempre
en esa semillita en los lectores y que
se animen a también investigar que que
se empieza a hablar otra vez de ellas
que sean temas de interés de análisis
para que se continuó escribiendo sobre
su legado y que quede allí para la
posteridad y además de la importancia de
los libros también descubrimos la
importancia de mantenernos conectados
con nuestras raíces nosotros recibimos
tantos mensajes de niños y devueltos de
diferentes partes del mundo que de
alguna manera se reencontraron con lo
que son y además se proyectaron como
agentes de cambio para un futuro que nos
dimos cuenta que el país más que un
donde es un como por qué y un pin para
quien uno con quien nosotras nos dimos
cuenta que venezuela vive en uno
hay que a pesar de estar en continentes
distintos usos horarios diferentes hay
algo que nos une y que nos hace partes
de un todo nuestras raíces son algo que
no nos van a poder quitar nunca siempre
van a estar allí para sostenernos para
recordarnos quiénes somos y sobre todo
para hacernos sentir orgullosos por eso
es importante que las preservemos que
las queremos y que también se les
transmita vamos a nuestros hijos
todos los días escuchamos en medios de
comunicaciones noticias desalentadoras
sobre el país pero cuando vemos una niña
venezolana que vive en eeuu y que
prepara un vídeo sobre carolina herrera
para para un trabajo del colegio de la
semana de la herencia hispana nos damos
cuenta que cuando esa niña puede hablar
con orgullo de carolina herrera y decir
con orgullo que esa mujer que tanto
admira es venezolana le estamos dando
razones para que crea para que crea que
ella también puede y estamos aumentando
su autoestima y su confianza y eso
definitivamente es una de las grandes de
las grandes
de los grandes logros de haber escrito
este libro
sí y otra cosa que hemos podido
disfrutar mucho este proceso es que si
ya antes nos sentimos muy orgullosas de
ser venezolanas ahora lo sentimos
muchísimo más no solo por conocer a
profundidad la historia plasmadas en el
libro sino porque nos ha permitido
recordar la bondad y la calidad del
venezolano con cada mensaje que hemos
recibido como dice vanessa en el que nos
cuentan su historia de reinvención en la
que nos cuentan lo que libro ha
significado para ellos y nos hemos dado
cuenta que ese sentimiento de
pertenencia al venezolano que está
templo y fuera venezuela está más
latente que nunca y que siempre busca
ahora venezuela en alto y una cosa que
no es queremos dejar pasar por alto es
que estas 20 mujeres que están en el
libro son una mínima muestra de todas
las mujeres venezolanas que cambian el
mundo cada una a su manera cada vez es
menor y a veces a mayor escala pero que
son mujeres que se esfuerzan todos los
días por salir a la calle por echarle
pichón puede ser una mejor versión de lo
que son del día anterior entonces para
nosotros es súper importante
recordar y darle el reconocimiento a
estas mujeres
de verdad maravilloso lo que me cuentan
y en ese proceso que ya nos hablaron del
aprendizaje cuáles son estos logros que
ustedes ya han visto y han tenido
después de este año que han publicado el
libro
mira nosotros estamos convencidas que
para lograr cambios dentro de la
sociedad la educación de temprana es
vital por eso si bien queríamos hacer un
libro que contará la historia de estas
venezolanas lo que hicimos hacer para
niños
la estructura del libro es como es por
esta razón son textos cortos lenguajes
simples imágenes coloridas y al final de
cada perfil hay una pequeña actividad en
la que invitamos a los niños a la
persona que lo está leyendo a seguir
conociendo a seguir investigando en una
invitación la curiosidad a la
creatividad a conectar en familia y a
comentar con las raíces
sí sí antes hablábamos de esa generación
de bienes que se disfrazaba de la
sirenita y que limpiaba la casa de los
siete enanitos ahora nos encontramos
frente a una generación que tiene otros
modelos a seguidos en estos 12 años de
estos 12 meses después de la publicación
del libro hemos conocido a una niña de
tercer grado que que descubrió la física
a través del libro y que se animó a
escribirle a miley sánchez para
preguntarle más sobre sus experimentos e
incluirlo en un trabajo por el college y
después concluía ahora sé que tengo un
modelo a seguir en la ciencia por el que
me quiero esforzar cada día tenemos
también los niños una comunidad warao en
el estado bolívar que reflexionaron
junto a amor y el fondo de pueblos
hambre las naciones unidas sobre el
papel de la mujer en la sociedad a
través de la historia de dina
castellanos o un grupo de niñas del
colegio san josé de tarbes que se
disfrazaron de las mujeres que más
admiran para hablar frente a su colegio
de sus retos de sus logros de su legado
o tenemos también el caso de una niña de
primaria en madrid que se animó a
hablarle a su clase sobre la historia de
teresa carreño y que a pesar de sus
citas marcadas nos decías por redes
sociales venezuela nunca saldrá de mi
sangre y con estas y otras muchas
anécdotas que recibimos a lo largo de
todo esto de este año nos dimos cuenta
de la riqueza de los libros de la fuerza
del ejemplo y del poder que tiene la
inspiración y todo esto nos dio motivos
para seguir creyendo que de verdad con
los sueños de los niños de hoy podemos
construir el mundo que queremos
miren de verdad para mí ha sido fabuloso
conversar con ustedes una última
recomendación para esos niños y niñas
que van a leer su libro y que como usted
dicen con sueños pueden cambiar el mundo
creo que lo más importante a destacar es
que entendamos que como venezolanos
somos muy valiosos que
que la situación por la que está pasando
el país ahora no nos determina que tanto
los niños como las niñas pueden ser
cualquier cosa que se propongan mientras
te trabaje fuerte mientras se sea
disciplinado mientras se se ha
determinado creo que este es como el
mensaje principal que queremos
transmitir y yo creería que 33
reflexiones aprendidas sobre estados
venezolanos que soñaron con cambiar el
mundo y sería bueno primero que nunca
hay un momento perfecto para empezar a
trabajar en nuestros sueños simplemente
hay que atreverse que nunca es tarde
para aprender cosas nuevas y para
empezar proyectos nuevos y yo diría que
una tercera que no importa lo que sea
que vayamos a hacer sea algo pequeño o
algo grande si lo hacemos con el corazón
siempre queda mejor
no puedo estar más de acuerdo con
ustedes porque si soñamos hay que
enseñar en grande y hay que inspirar
como tocaba decir con el corazón de
verdad muchísimas gracias y ha sido un
placer para mí entrevistar la devora y
vanessa sobre no solamente su libro sino
el aprendizaje que son ustedes y cómo a
través de esto pueden inspirar a esta
nueva generación de niños y niñas que
van a ser el futuro del país
bueno muchísimas gracias de verdad
[Música]